I'm Glen Howerton from Dane cook. It's your boy, DJ Pauly, D and Vinnie. G yo,
what up? I'm Nick cannon. My name is [inaudible] I'm Jim Norton, Andrea Savage,
Brendan shop Andrew Schultz. Karen Fisher, Bob Saget. I know.
Hold your applause. I'm Steve, this is Kevin Heffernan.
Chris's Stefano and John. Yes. And I'm Joey boy. I was a boy.
I am Tom I'm Theo. I'm about to,
to answer the internet. I had bronchitis
have a good hand job from your grandma. Good God does.
Or a bad hand job from your grandma. Your mother.
That's a bad one.
You don't want a good cause you want to be thinking about it the next week.
You want to be like, Oh, that was terrible. Old Brinkley hands.
What would be the one song you want played at your funeral? Yo,
I got a new. Yeah, everybody better do the dance while I'm in my cast.
The one celebrity birthday party you would want to attend.
Um, you choose bono cause I'm not really a fan. So I'd just walk out.
I just leave. I'd be like Bano I'm out.
Thanks and have sex with anyone you want or transport anywhere
in the world. Yeah. Okay. Well then I guess, uh, I guess I,
I guess I'd want to just, yeah.
Snap the fingers and transport go wherever the I want, I don't want to have sec.
What am I going to get chlamydia again? Uh,
would you rather have a threesome with two female literal people done it
or three? So with the seven foot tall,
I'll never had seven foot tall chick.
So I would go with that one because I did the little bit,
sorry I'm have done it.
You have to do it internationally.
International it's internet. You got it's international. Isn't Dubai.
How did this come about? It was one night.
They were rushing in Dubai crazy story, but they were like, yeah,
man, it was a good night, but that was also the night. I was like,
I think I've gone too far.
They got me through.
But do you want to sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter
you've had or watch your parents' sex tape when they
conceived?
You ha I'd rather sit down and watch my own sexual thing because I've already
seen Polaroids of when they conceived me. Get outta here. Yeah. Why?
My father took pictures. My mother had a good. Show them to you.
Check it out. Yeah, exactly.
It was like looking through the Hubble telescope and seeing the beginning of
time. But was my dad my mom from the back. Would you rather yourself?
Every time you have orgasm or get a random every time you talk to a dude,
I, I would rather myself. Every time I had an orgasm,
I already do do myself every time. Yeah.
But that's a double orgasm because taking a is fantastic. It's orgasmic. Yeah.
Right. You just be like, I mean, that's the ultimate pleasure.
Orgasm is at the same time. Right down to it. This is a super easy question.
Yeah. I'd definitely rather.
That's what's stupid about the question is how easy it is.
If you could only watch one category of porn for the rest of your life,
would it be a boy? Um,
it's a toss up between barely legal and
because I just want new people coming into the pipeline. You know what I mean?
And those are the two.
So depending on where my issues lay probably barely legal.
I have to say it barely though. It's barely remember that word is barely.
You have a choice between a sum of money and world peace.
How much money would it take for you to give up world peace?
I'm not giving up world peace.
I have enough money. I'm fine. Or is it all my money taken away? Now I'm broke.
You have $0 world peace or a hundred billion dollars.
I don't need a hundred billion dollars that causes a lot of problems.
Well, world piece or 10, if you're broke.
Well, if I'm broken, I have to like survive and I've got my kid. Yeah.
I don't know. Couple hundred thousand for a year.
I mean, she's got to go to private school.
You are in an open field, armed with a baseball bat.
Picture that. Okay. How many ten-year-olds wearing bike helmets.
Could you take down before they get you?
So just a wave of ten-year-olds coming at you and game of Thrones. Oh,
it wouldn't matter. I'd get them all.
Absolutely infinite. I'd destroy those kids.
10 years old. Oh, they're. Yeah.
I'd be John Snow. I'd be jive. I'd be John Snow all over that.
Just ten-year-old bodies all over the place. It was a little idiots.
Think what are they going to do to me? Idiots.
You had to pick one person to be the ambassador for the human race to meet
aliens. Who would it be? Ooh, this is good. I probably pay,
um, probably a Filipino dude. I'm really infatuated about the Latinos.
They're happy. They're joyous. You know,
they call them the smiling people somewhere on the internet. And um,
and every Filipino I meet, they're real gracious.
They do a lot of senior care centers, hospice. So you don't,
who else are you going to send out there, dude? You know what I'm saying?
A drunk, uh, you know, uh, somebody from Scotland know somebody on Coke.
We can't do any of that. You got to send somebody who is caring. I think.
Can you just say like the rock
[inaudible] we're good on. Yeah. Yeah. Maybe Manny Pacquiao.
Would you rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick or
sit on a Dick if, either kick
yo you know what? This is depends how big the Dick and cake are. Right?
Like if it's a small Dick, like if it's,
if it's like half a pinky, right? That's a thorough wipe.
That's not even really sex. Do you know what I mean? Like,
I'm going deeper in there to get Dingleberry. So if it's a small Dick,
I'd rather sit on the Dick and then eat a cake.
It doesn't matter the size of cake. Right? It's going to be slight discomfort.
It's like carrying a shank into prison. It's not even gay.
I'm just protecting myself
without a doubt. I'm not eating a Dick. That's nuts.
Calm, loudly. Every time you fart or fart loudly,
every time you come, yo, if you came loudly, every time you fart,
you would've came 19 times on the way over here.
Quito part smells like you have no idea. I find a lot.
No it lingers. I'm going to fart loudly. Every time I come.
Would you rather watch your, Oh,
watch your parents have sex every night or join in one
night. Oh my God. Oh my God. I mean,
I'd have to watch it because I'm not joining in my dad's way
to Fly home. And I'm like,
am I a mountain climber? Or am I having sex on my desk?
I can't. When someone's two I'm five foot three he's six foot six.
So how is logistics even gonna work? Come on guys. Wow. Drama.
Just talk about you're your dad.
I heard somebody over there. Go sheesh.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather have a Dick as your nose or nose as your Dick? Definitely.
A nose is my Dick. Cause then you could blow my nose.
[Inaudible].
No one upset you, but I'm not on antibiotics,
but it's viral. Take them anyway. Kids.
If people tell you don't take antibiotics because it's not bacteria.
They're full of. Take drugs no matter what and stay in school,
which fictional character would you love to be the.
I mean, you're not real, right? I mean,
you're not everyone here at the office calls you nothing but a phony.
So I think it, you,
Hey, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Can we go back? Hey, I'm sorry. No,
that wasn't called for. I said I was sorry. I'm sorry. I'll change.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Okay. Your mom and girlfriend switched bodies, huh?
Only way to get them back to normal is to bang. One of them.
Who do you have sex with?
I said I was sorry. I said I was, I mean,
I feel, if I say girlfriend I'll somehow offend my mom. I don't know why.
Throw Adam Schefter over a field goalpost. Yes.
I've literally seen Rob pick up both of my sisters on his arms and just like
while they hang like monkeys. So if, if Adam's a little guy,
he could definitely pick them up and throw him easy. Rob benches me.
There's no problem.
If you're a Dick was represented by an NFL player,
who would it be? It would be Rashad. Jenna.
You'd rather sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter you've
had or watch your parents' sex tape when they've conceived you the sex tape when
they conceived me. Why? Because it's the greatest moment that ever happened.
Would you rather date an ugly rich dude or a poor good looking guy? Very rich,
very ugly, very poor, very hot, rich and ugly. Well,
Joey did actually get with a rich guy for free shoes
for free. Sure.
They were really expensive shoes and I just got an all fours and um,
let him eat his, but yeah, he was 75 years old,
75 year old. I still have the shoes today.
There were like $700 shoes that was worth it.
You've been put in charge of running. Heck
the afterlife for people not evil enough for hell.
What's the first torture you design.
Oh yeah. It's just, I just have them wait in a lot of lines. You know,
like lines are kind of the worst thing and you know what I would have,
I would make it so that the,
the waiting line that they're in has a bunch of other people having public
speaker phone and FaceTime conversations.
So they're just sitting there and they're like, well, everyone shut the other.
One's like, no, we gotta keep talking. So like,
it's just like just makes them crazy that everyone would shut up. You know,
that's, that's what Garth Brooks is going to suffer. One day.
You can have sex with anyone want.
But they die immediately after who or Oh,
or just who do you have sex with?
Throw. I got one for you. A Casey Anthony.
That's a great answer. Call me, call me Dick justice.
That's for Kaylee
thing to say after you come and kill ya, that one was,
I don't think that was wrong, either dumb. Right?
Other than everyone agrees with me, you don't have the balls to push it.
I'm coming for
that wrong spark. You that little girl,
would you rather sit down with your parents and watch every sexual encounter
they ever had the internet, the internet,
or you gotta watch the sex tape, but when your parents conceived, you.